[Music]  i'm alicia cunha and i've been at fox  news for 24 years i was a local reporter  and anchor in fresno california 27 years  old and my agent called me one day and  said the fox news channel wants to hire  you i said  oh what's that and i go out to los  angeles meet the bureau chief there and  he says to me  we're going to go after cnn and they're  going to kill us but we're going to go  after them anyway alicia cunha fox news  something about the idea of this little  guy going after this big guy  spoke to me and i was in  think about it a brand new cable channel  going after cnn  it sounded absurd that feeling that i  got when he said we're gonna go after  them that has never left me we have a  history with each other  and that matters